Hideki Matsuyama was first introduced to the game at age 4...
...by his father, Mikio, at the local driving range.
Young Hideki was hooked on the game.
Hideki's trips to the range were infrequent.
But, his father saw a strong passion early on from the boy.
As the boy grew into a man, his game began to flourish.
Young Hideki became so good in fact,...
...he came to the US while still an amateur.
He played at the Sony Open and the Masters.
His first brush with golfing royalty,...
...he realized quickly there were still more work to be done.
He attended college at Tohoku Fukushi University in Sendai,...
...winning the Asian Amateur Championship in both 2010 and 2011,...
...becoming one of the most decorated amateur players ever from Japan.
He would join the PGA Tour full-time in 2014,...
...earning his first PGA Tour victory at the 2014 Memorial Tournament...
...presented by Nationwide,...
...culminating the handshake from the legendary host, The Golden Bear, Jack Nicklaus.
In subsequent seasons, he would amass 4 more PGA Tour wins,...
...becoming the winningest Japanese player in PGA Tour history,...
...all by the age of 24.
His best season on the PGA Tour came in 2017.
Hideki winning the Waste Management Phoenix Open...
...and the World Golf Championships.
He reached second in the official World Golf ranking,...
...the highest ever for a male Japanese golfer.
And while golf has taken him all over the world,...
...in his heart and mind, he's still that little boy from Ehime...
...with the oversized club and a funny pose in his swing.